when we said that the framework didn't
want us to run network operations on the
main thread what is the main thread
well Android apps run by default on the
main thread also called the UI thread it
handles all the user input as well as
the output such as screen drawing thus
we want to avoid any time consuming
operations here otherwise the UI is
going to stutter instead kickoff a
background work or thread if you have to
do some long-running work this includes
doing Network calls decoding bitmaps or
reading and writing from the database
okay so somehow we have to move the
networking code off the main thread but
how are we going to do that well there
are several options but let's look for
the name of the Android class that
simplifies background thread creation
and UI thread synchronization so the
results from the background work will
come back onto the main thread and then
we can use it to update our UI search
online and figure out the answer to this
question and then enter the class name
in the box here's some advice for you
if you ever get stuck on how to do
something in Android and you can't find
it on the developer site you can try to
check Stack Overflow comm it's a
question and answer site that many
Android developers use as a valuable
resource so chances are likely that
someone already has adds a similar
question that you have